you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I just got paired up playing a
5-2 game okay
let's try something like this
symmetrical English okay let's get my
night out and hmm g 6d 6d v many
possibilities let's go with this oh okay
things are heating up in the center I
just play a six
I could take don't know if I really want
to do that at least not just yet
let me play here and should I take care
d tasty for do you take C for if Queen a
for a bishop d7 if I'm playing the
smoove it's not like I'm trying to hang
on to that pond but I'd at least like to
like them to like to see them work a
little hard to try and hunt that pond
back down let's see how they go about
that are they gonna do Queen a for
Bishop d7 we take C pawn takes pawn
Knight takes pawn rook c8 or maybe even
first on Queen a4 I could take here I
have to be concerned of this move that I
did not suspect that does not seem
correct okay I just take wine up and
where does my bishop belong a seven now
let's just go to e7 so they're working
with an isolated pawn my struggle will
be to make sure I get my LightSquared
Bishop developed although I don't think
that that should be too difficult let's
start with this end rook to see a knight
v5 into here excuse me Knight be 4 into
d5 also Knight be 4 with Bishop c6 I'd
like a light square bishop exchange that
way I can rely upon this d5 squares a
nice home for my pieces I'm expecting
Knight to e5 right now and I'm gonna
have to be alright with giving up my
light square bishop in fact maybe I win
this pawn Knight takes bishop and Knight
takes Knight I'm hitting d4 twice B down
the bishop pair but I have something to
bite again bite out d4 pawn Queen b6
rook here seems pretty sensible they
can't get this break in just yet maybe
rook to d1
you know I'm wrecked ad1 if I take I'm
going right into a pin no they're not
doing that if I take now I'm on the
Queen so there's no time for our pin a
knight takes D this ship takes Queen
takes Bishop takes pawn I think I'll be
fine with that okay
I'm pretty sure I've equalized here yeah
pretty confident with that
so I guess here I need a flight square
still and their pawn on f2 is pinned
don't know if that's something I could
take advantage of but okay Queen B 4 is
maybe an idea how are they defending
their beep on let's see let's see how
they defend the B pawn rook to b1 nada
not a happy move to play this rook isn't
doing anything I think this is a fine
square what flight square for my king
ideally I'd like to Wow g6 but maybe
even something like this is an idea it's
a nice fast move tucking in the king
keeping him on a light square this
Bishop is an excellent piece
hmm you know I guess we're gonna go with
this and I have a quick move to get in
at some point okay I guess King up yeah
you know rattle my queen physician now
okay let's try this now expecting h4
otherwise I could be playing h4 okay
Brooke d4 it's an improvement for my
rook it stops a knight here and I guess
they're going for a rook to d2 I'd like
to reroute my bishop yeah my bishop
could certainly try and find something
better to do maybe get it on this dog
and I'll point at f2 which is there
which is a sensitive point should I
transfer my attention to the D file hmm
you know let's try that
I've got coordination ripped to c7 okay
I could enter now on D to write D to
Queen c5 hmm maybe this is a move
actually and challenge that bishops but
let's let's try that move first think
later hmm maybe let's come all the way
back I feel like all the other squares
are gonna be she could be challenged
he's a loose piece I'm guarding against
the seventh rank stuff moving the night
does not save the bishop I have enough
support for this I guess the Queen
Esther move I like my position this is a
strong night good rooks I'm looking to
improve further though namely my darks
Knight
I only have one bishop looking to
improve my bishop I want to get him here
but it's covered for right now if I can
make this happen Bishop c5 I will have
really really good pieces all around so
what are they considering here what
Queen move do they have they have to do
something awkward like Queen here here
yeah well let's start with that I could
even improve my Queen Queen to e5 hmm
well actually let's do this maybe I
could get this move in next No
okay well I think this Knight is the
glue let's try and get rid of the glue
maybe I could then push and challenge
their King physician if I could make
this f-pawn flinch with my epon I think
that that would be nice
okay we're going to take and expose my
own King but uh I want to make sure I
don't lose that epon and this maybe is a
fine home for my king I do have my rooks
that could contest any pressure on the
second or the seventh rank and maybe
even f4 I consider this I have some
aggressive intentions maybe as well with
f4 scratch that oh I could take now I
can't Bishop takes and then they're
getting stuff
all right that's a that's a very
interesting move let's just go here now
this is a fine home for my King King
here Bishop on f6 Bishop on g7
would be an excellent defense Oh King
here gonna challenge my queen yes okay
let's go here on bishop here I have rook
to d2 I might be quite alright with
giving up that pond and I think they'd
be very very greedy if they take that
pawn very very greedy
are they greedy Wow okay well let's take
and the rook is kind of stuck let's make
sure I don't lose that pawn maybe this
other rook here would have been better
because it stops rook c3 although and
rook c3 a Brooke d2 interesting endgame
opposite color bishops I'm not thinking
that this is a draw in any way the rook
is struggling I definitely have the more
active pieces let's stay active get
behind these ponds okay maybe improve my
bishops position get on this diagonal
this is what I've been wanting for my
bishop for some time
and let's actually go here try and put a
halt to their their pawn movements
improve my King position I have to be
careful because of bishop - eh hmm I
don't know how much further I want to go
with my King to be honest I think we're
a little bit out of standstill here
excuse me a little bit out of standstill
I don't want to go any further
mm-hmm let's see if they're gonna try
for more actually don't I have an
opportunity for this oh my goodness I
just dropped my bro mm I resign oh I
missed that Bishop takes rook that's bad
I mean I have a draw with this but I'm
looking at doing something like this and
then rook here I just dropped my rook oh
man I wonder if I had a win here I know
it's at least a draw because of my
position in my bishop position but it's
tricky still because I can't go too far
away because of this stuff you know what
these guys still fixed on dark their
prime targets for my bishop and with my
pawns fixed on light they're targets for
this guy so we have to hmm be careful we
don't drop our puns and of course we
don't drop our rook like I did but yeah
this was an interesting game let me go
into the analysis fortunate end they're
dropping a ruck but let's see about this
one the d4 move yeah okay even ish
yeah I didn't think that this was a well
it didn't scare me at least the III move
there's something better than III hmm so
if I was clean out right away I could
take night takes and then even here a
nun takes I have Bishop d7 okay yeah I'd
be fine with that yeah if I could um I
mean what happened in the game I had my
light square Bishop exchange for their
King night if it's the case my light
square bishop is exchanged for their
light square bishop all the better
no imbalance you know they don't have
that Trump in that of the bishop pair
and I have no opening issues he's he has
a tendency to be there's a tendency to
have it be a bit difficult to get the
Queen Bishop developed because of the
bishop operating on this main diagonal
putting pressure on these Queen side
squares okay so I took III even-even ish
night before I was too quick to allow
that pawn to be taken right back I was
content with just chasing the Queen
around bitching with Bishop d7 I guess I
can make them work a little bit harder
huh the night before popped up there for
a second and now Bishop d7 ah okay so
this is an interesting way to look at it
I was only seeing it as okay let's yes
they'll get the pawn back but I'll be
grabbing a valuable tempo against the
Queen with my rook but maybe I could
also see it as
in what you know my journey to the sea
six square d7 c6 I could gain a tempo
against the Queen on a4 and this is a
move I'll want to play anyway as well
and I can make them struggle some so you
get the c4 pawn back hmm I'm learning
these little details I like learning of
these little details here night to be 4
and then Bishop d7 and then night here
uh-huh okay noted so I let them get that
pond back and that wants to take what
upon mmm okay oh well excuse me I didn't
night-night b5 wasn't played okay this
is this is the game here Bishop d7 Queen
takes rook see it I was wondering what
just happened there green returns
playing against this isolated pawn you
know it's an even game even even even
what is missed right around here does it
stay even right until the end
it sure felt like it was even I don't
know that my opponent gave me anything
and I don't know that I gave my opponent
anything until that final move rook d2
earlier I felt that on rook here I don't
know like Queen here and I don't really
know what I have the other
ters clean here my rook takes pawn hmm
you know here's another thing I was
seeing that on this if I do Queen if I
do rip to d2 I was seeing that on Queen
c4 that I have to take but I don't I
have have defense my queen so I guess I
could have done one better here and
immediately made use of the D 2 square
lady for instead trying to put in bring
to quite bring into question the bishop
on f3 whose short on squares back on e4
yeah it's it's pretty even ish here
trying to get rid of the knight does
like f5 no tight game anything missed
anything serious here ooh -
here what am I missing rook here King
there and then oh there's no time for
them to grab this apon I got that whoo
this would have been nice
I'm quicker to get my rooks on the
second-ranked
who cares about that a pawn how could I
have better viewed this position because
I was too fixated with this rook move
clearly I was too fixated on hanging
onto the material but I have control of
some light squares around there King I
can also potentially control these dark
squares with my bishop no doubt and
combine that with activating not just
one but two rooks on the second rank and
potentially dislodging this rook from e3
I should care much less about this a
pawn I know when he falls the have
connected passed pawns but I should have
something pretty serious with both rooks
on the second rank combined with a
bishop on this diagonal and a connected
passed pond those are a lot of a lot of
things to weigh in are a lot of things
to consider in this position instead of
wanted to hang
to everything hmm
okay another little mental note for me
so I should just go straight in for this
and not fear this kind of stuff well
most directly because of this I mean
it's just it's not working just to this
one move threat but even if that wasn't
the case just getting the rooks on the
second-ranked and you know even if
Bishop d4 wasn't hitting with this Fork
of the the rooks it was just a real lot
of play that I would have alright well I
just neutralized the rook here rip c7
rook d7 still have some advantage
because I have the more active rook and
their King is cut off but is it really
enough right around here yeah this is
where we repeated some if I approach you
know you see I could I could only go so
far I can't I can't allow these guys to
be hunted down yeah I really can't do
much more I did consider I I didn't
voice it but I did think about rook
Chuck but what am i doing after King
here Oh
rook there they could offset it with
rook here minus one
I'm not sure how are things looking in
this ending well you know they're gonna
be the ones fighting for a draw yeah
yikes well how did this one end
I dropped my rope does that ever happen
with you happens with me and you saw at
first and unfortunate end to this one it
was a really tight one right through
really and some different ways that I
could really be looking at positions
like this well first first off in this
middle game position really getting into
that a second rank much sooner or at
least considering it a bit more getting
into that d 2 square and when it did get
to this point here don't be too
concerned about that a pond when you
could get two pigs on the second alright
well as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below and as usual I hope you
got something out of it that's all for
now take care bye
you